[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON MARSHALL: I am
in a tiny percentage
of people in the world that can
literally work from anywhere.
And that was freedom for me.
One of my family
values is we think
life is about living
great stories.
And so to move to Cape
Town, started this business,
and live like this, we
think is a great story.
The possibilities
are endless here.
We love it.
Over is a simple app for
adding text to photos.
You can rotate the
text, change the color,
really dial into customization.
We offer hundreds of fonts.
And we're always loading
new fonts in there
that you can unlock.
We also have artwork,
some of it exclusive.
The decision for us to go
to Android was obvious.
80% of the global
market is using Android.
And we were really passionate
about helping people
be creative, and
that was an easy way
to get to a lot more people.
JONATHAN ORFORD:
It's everywhere.
It's growing very, very quickly.
And we want to be
a part of that.
The high-end and
the low-end devices
all support Over, which
is fantastic for us.
When we decided to develop
the application for Android,
I had two developers
already in mind.
They had Java experience,
but very limited Android
experience.
They managed to get up to
speed very, very quickly,
and we were able to start
writing code within days.
JOHAN NELL: I joined Over with
no prior Android experience.
And myself and Herko were able
to get a working prototype out
to Aaron within the first week.
HERKO LATEGAN: My
experience in developing
Over for Android
was really quick.
It took us two months.
And originally,
our product manager
thought it was going
to take a lot longer.
And I think that the main
benefit of working on Android
was the tools are amazing.
You've got Android Studio.
And you've got all
of this documentation
just at your fingertips,
which makes it easy for us.
JONATHAN ORFORD: We're
offering our application
to as many countries
as we possibly can,
and therefore we have
to adjust the pricing.
And some countries want
rounded pricing, some don't.
We have complete control of our
pricing with the Google Play
Developer Console.
It's one place I can
go and see everything.
I can go and see statistics.
I can go and see my rollouts.
I can see ratings and reviews.
It's brilliant.
And it's all in one place
and very, very easy to use.
AARON MARSHALL: I really like
the Google Play experience.
I can actually talk to the
customers in the reviews.
And that customer connection
is hugely valuable.
If you don't know
what they're thinking,
if you can't interact and
talk and ask questions,
it's hard to figure
out what's valuable.
And driving value
to customers is
what a company and a
start-up is all about.
JOHAN NELL: I remember the
first day when we launched,
just looking at the
analytics and seeing people
starting and using
the application
and then going on to the
social networking services
and seeing these pieces of
art, these images people
are creating with
code we've written.
The creativity that it
inspires is jaw-dropping.
It was really exciting.
AARON MARSHALL: Around
Over we have a mantra.
We like to say, go
big and go home.
We don't think you should
be sacrificing your family
in order to make some wealth
or create value or change
the world.
What good is it to have
all of those things
if you don't have a family
to then share in that success
with?
So for us, success
is two-pronged.
We want to go big, and
we want to go home.